Before we get started today
we just wanna let you know
that we got just a
handful of concerts left.
A handful.
For this year, and it's the
only ones we have planned
into the future at this point.
So if you wanna see us do musical comedy.
Oh yeah.
You can come to Albuquerque,
New Mexico, on November 20th,
Phoenix, Arizona on the 21st,
Sacramento, California on the 22nd,
and Valley Center,
California, on November 23rd.
Singing some songs.
We're gonna make these real special shows
because we aint gonna do 'em for a while.
So come on up.
RhettAndLinkLive.com.
That's RhettAndLinkLive.com.
Get your tickets there.
Don't just google it and click
on the first place you see.
That's right.
Now on with the biscuit.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're discussing, but
this is your brain child,
how do you wanna put this?
Uh, well, the catchy way to talk about it
is our we out of touch?
But the way we're going to discover
just how out of touch
we might be, if we are--
With ourselves?
With aliens?
With what?
With generation Z.
Oh.
Are we losing our grip on the trend,
on the currency of pop culture?
And our kids are generation Z, by the way.
Can you look up what officially,
Jacob, can you look up
officially what years
you were supposed to be
born in to be generation Z?
Just to verify that.
Just so when we come back to
it I can seem knowledgeable.
And is there, what generation are we?
Actually, we are--
41/42 year old old farts.
We're right, so a lot of
people call us xennials,
I think is what some people call us,
because we're basically
right in between generation X
and milennials, and we're
not really either one.
If you're like 41, 42 years old,
you're this, I think it's
xennials or x-xennials.
Okay.
Is there a generation Y?
Yeah.
You missed it man.
No one cares about those, those people.
We're off to the Zs,
which Jacob will clarify
if that's our children.
There is a rough range
and then a specific range
that some people use.
Born between 1995 and 2015.
Right, so all of our children.
Yeah, you know, here's the thing.
I just take pride in the
fact that in this town,
when I tell people, when it
comes up that we have kids,
it's like oh you got kids?
And I'm like, "Yeah, I got a 16 year old."
And then it's like their face just drops.
Yeah they can't believe it.
You know, in this town.
So I'm just grateful
that I got kids that old
and I still feel this young.
But I am I in touch with them?
A 16 year old, a 14 year
old and a nine year old.
I'll get into, well we're gonna go through
some generation Z slang
that was on a list that's...
The way that the list was
created is very funny,
and so I'll get into that when
we get into the conversation.
You're gonna test me.
I'm gonna run through it with you,
see if you know this stuff.
It's pretty long, I don't know
how much we'll get through.
I'm gonna tell you whether
or not I knew that stuff.
But the reason I thought about doing this
was because I don't even
remember where I was
but I realized that I was saying something
and I was like I think I sound old.
Because I specifically listen
to the way my kids talk
and some of the lingo that they use.
In fact lingo's probably a
word that makes me sound old.
You know what I'm saying?
Like lingo, what's that dad?
And I realized that if I'm
like excited about something
or if I'm trying to tell somebody
that I think something's great,
I might say like, "That's awesome."
And then I was like I don't think my kids
would ever say that something
was awesome anymore.
I don't hear them say that.
No.
My kids don't use the word awesome.
And so I just started realizing that like
oh yeah, even though we
are in this medium that
is still considered new media,
and people look at us as like oh yeah
those young guys on the internet,
we're not, we're old, and we've got kids
that are getting older
and about to go to college
in just a couple years.
And we are definitely out
of touch to some degree.
Today we're gonna find out
just how out of touch we are.
Mm.
I'd like to give an update on
my shower window situation.
Yeah, it's quite a situation.
Though it has nothing to
do with being in touch.
Unless you wanna talk about me
being in touch with my neighbor,
who I can see out of my shower
window while I'm showering.
Can you talk about in as, without having,
you haven't seen any of the lingo,
can you talk about it as
if you're in generation Z?
Perhaps bro.
Wow, that's off to a rough start.
Perhaps.
As I've preev established--
You think they use the word perhaps?
As I've preev established, my peeps,
my shower is totally lit,
because well it's actually,
it'd be hard to light anything in there
in terms of like setting anything on fire
because it's so wet in there.
Right, you'd have a waterproof light.
A shower light.
It's a special light.
Well there are lights in there.
There are to recessed
lights above the shower,
which I don't use because I have a window
which lets in all of my natural light
and so it is lit, by the
natural glow of the environment.
You don't ever take
showers when it's dark?
Very, very rarely.
I take 'em in the morning.
But interestingly enough,
there are exceptions,
and my update is related
to an exceptional time
that I took a shower,
because, I don't know,
if you haven't been
listening to all these,
don't feel guilty, I'm
bringing you up to speed.
Actually feel a little bit guilty.
You're missing out on...
Yeah you should keep up.
On the updates.
But the fact that Rhett told me
when I see my neighbor leaving for work
and I'm in the shower, shampooing,
I gotta make eye contact
and assert my dominance.
I can't remember why, and I definitely--
It was for the future, it was for when
the world falls apart and
you're asserting yourself
as a leader of your community.
And especially 'cause
I can't remember why,
I don't remember why I actually tried it,
but I did.
And then ever since then his car's gone
when I get in the shower,
and my routine's the same.
So I think my dominance led
him to adjust his routine
to go to work earlier,
just so he doesn't have to
almost see my out the corner of his eye
staring at him when
I'm shampooing my hair.
Now, as I've established,
the window is a wide screen format window,
and it exposes me from
the collar bones up,
I think from his vantage point,
when he's in his driveway, backing out,
and he looks forward he can see me.
But over this past weekend
I went mountain biking,
me and Lincoln went mountain biking.
I didn't ask him to describe it,
but he wouldn't have said awesome,
and he wouldn't have said lit.
You really gave up on
the generation Z thing
pretty early in this.
Yeah it's tough, too tough.
So then when I got back, and let's see,
it was probably, well it was kinda late,
it was dinner time, it
was like six or 6:30,
and I was like well I
need to take a shower,
you know, I'm pretty sweaty.
So I get in there and I'm taking a shower,
and I'm still, I got my
window open, I'm looking out.
It's like oh the sun's kinda going down,
this is a beautiful time to take a shower
and enjoy my window.
And I looked at the driveway and I saw
my neighbor's car there.
He was not in the car.
And then I turned a little bit further,
and I looked in a place
that I had not looked,
and it was my neighbor's house.
How have you not looked there?
Well, because I'm looking
out at the majestic scenery.
There's like mountains and stuff.
I'm not gonna look at his house.
No, I do, can I just
interject and say that
you talk about seeing the
scenery while showering
as if the only time you see
the scenery around your house
is while showering.
Like out of every other
window it doesn't exist,
or perhaps, bro, if you go outside,
maybe you would also see it.
Like you talk about it
like you're on a spaceship
that has like a Holodeck situation,
and the only way to experience
what Earth was like at one time
is to go take this shower.
The only other place I can see this
vantage point of the mountains
is if I walk out my front door,
which is nice, you know, you're exiting,
you get to see it, but I
don't have any other windows.
Like both boys have a
window in their bedroom
that faces that same direction,
but that's the only four places
you can see that vantage point.
And I'm in the shower every day.
I gotta look at something.
And it's not gonna be my neighbor's house,
but I happened to look over there,
and they put in a new
window, they remodeled,
after I put in my shower window.
And I looked through that
window and I realized
I'm looking at the family
next door eat dinner.
No.
Yeah.
How have you not seen
the dinner table so far?
'Cause they haven't been at it?
They've never been at it.
So it's just like kind of
a dark window into nothing.
So now I'm freakin'
showering, and I'm looking at,
and he's at the head of
the table looking at me.
Eating his dinner.
Oh the tables have turned.
I'm like man.
I feel like a heel.
He was slow playing you.
He lulled you into thinking
that your dominance had worked.
He's like I'm gonna leave
early a couple of times
but I'm just waiting for
that day he accidentally
takes a shower while we're eating dinner
and I'm gonna stare him down.
A man looking at you while he's eating
is especially dominant.
Yeah, I wasn't eating.
He has the upper hand.
In the history of the animal kingdom,
while you're eating, like this
is when you show who's boss,
and if you can eat and look
at somebody in the eye,
you own them.
He owns you.
'Cause eating is survival.
It's like I'm currently taking in
the calories I need to dominate you.
Are you eating right now?
No, you're just getting clean.
Who needs to be clean?
Yeah, right.
Oh my gosh, I think you're right,
'cause you know what?
What was the expression on his face?
That was two days ago.
And then this morning I'm taking a shower,
my normal allotted morning time--
He's back in the car.
I look out there and--
Yeah, he did it.
I swear to you, he was in his car.
He was in his car!
This guy, he must be
listening to the podcast.
He was really in his car.
And I really had a hard
time looking at him.
I really tried to like make it...
I think this is your dominance.
You're controlling me, man.
I'm sitting here staring at a guy
eating dinner with his family.
I will say, I'm having a lot of fun.
It's wrong, man.
And I've never seen this man.
Actually you know what--
I felt bad.
But nobody wants to watch a dude shower
while they're eating
dinner, with their family,
two young kids!
The other day when I was
dropping Shepherd off
at your house, they
were getting in the car,
and I was like oh I get to see this guy.
But he got in the car right as I realized.
I got a good look at his wife.
I mean I didn't like make a,
I didn't try to dominate her
with my looks or anything.
But I didn't get a good
look at the husband.
And every time I talk about this,
Christy and Lily just tell me,
"Dad, you gotta stop talking about this."
I mean I think--
Oh you mean on this podcast?
Yes!
And I can't stop talking about it.
I mean I just can't help
but give you an update
because it's just all in my mind,
and are you planting
these things in my mind?
Because Christy's like, "You
didn't really look at him
"out the window, you're just
saying that for the podcast."
And I'm like, "No I did, I did."
But you know, like my sense
of reality's being blurred
by you and this shower window.
Listen, you're gonna thank me later.
For what?
When you've got that guy,
when you've got a dog collar
on that guy and you've got
a chain around his neck,
like 15 years from now.
He's listening!
I'm convinced, he's listening.
After the big one
happens, you'll thank me.
If he's there tomorrow morning, man.
And what if he's eating?
Well I mean it takes a little time between
us recording then releasing the episode,
then him listening to
it and him deciding to
take a turkey leg into his
car as he's going to work,
and dominate me by eating in his car.
If that happens, if he eats,
if he makes eye contact with
you while eating in the car,
he's definitely listening.
Oh gosh.
Now 'cause you talked about
your neighbor like a year ago,
and the whole thing about
like the tree and stuff.
And we completely
reconciled the whole thing.
I wouldn't say we're
friends at this point,
but we're in regular communication about
if somebody's gonna have
a loud party or whatever.
Well my wife is also in
communication with your neighbor.
My neighbors?
Yeah, she knows her now.
She met her around town.
No.
Yeah.
How does she know, how?
They work out at the gym together.
How does she know--
And then they see each other around town.
But how did it come out?
I don't know how Christy put
it together, but she did.
Well it doesn't matter,
we're good friends.
We exchange wine at Christmas time.
I mean that's a sign of a good neighbor.
Maybe if I get in the
shower with food next time,
then I can still assert my dominance.
And I do think it should
be a large turkey leg.
It's gotta be like meat
on a bone type situation.
This is the one time where a turkey leg
makes all sense, because--
Like a tomahawk cut...
Like a large beef rib.
Beef rib.
Could be that.
It's hard to come by though.
Turkey legs, dime a dozen.
And you don't wanna do like a corn dog
'cause that'll disintegrate in the shower.
I might have to keep it,
yeah, 'cause you're right,
I might have to keep that slab of meat
in the shower until the right opportunity,
and then I'll have to
pick it up and eat it.
It's gonna have to be there.
This is, I mean...
I think you know what you gotta do next.
Yeah, I feel good about this.
I think, I think this
is the right decision.
The saga continues, man.
I look forward to seeing how it goes.
You really gotta come up in my shower.
Yeah I'm really interested.
It worked before.
You get a turkey leg in
there, I'll come up there.
A nice steamy turkey leg.
Okay we're gonna see just
how out of touch we are,
but first, we wanna let you know,
what are we telling
people about this time?
Bleak Creek merch, is
just, it's been out a week.
So you can get it--
No it hasn't been out a week,
it drops when you're hearing this, right?
This is the video for it.
I know this is confusing.
But this ad only lives
in the video version.
That's right.
See, I got a sharp mind.
It's been out a week.
Been out a week.
So this pig pickin' shirt
is an authentic replica
of one that you might
get at a pig pickin',
but this is related to the book.
And we've got a hyper color shirt
that changes color, temperature sensitive,
just like the one we
reference in the book.
It says Bleak Creek on it.
We got the lost causes shirt.
We got a Buies Creek School,
Bleak Creek School sweatshirt,
it says Bleak Creek demons on it.
What else have we got?
Oh, all types of stuff.
Check it out.
Mythical.com.
And also, there's a book that
all the merch comes from,
called The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek.
Buy it for a friend if
you already have one.
Or if you don't have one, why
haven't you bought one yet?
Come on, read y'all.
You know?
The more you know.
LeVar Burton and Reading
Rainbow and things.
All right, thank you for
supporting entertainment,
repping your boys.
Okay, um, so there was an article--
And you know what, before we get in,
I did wanna mention, I
wanted to acknowledge
everyone who's talking about
Lost Causes of Bleak Creek.
On the Mythical Society there's great
conversations happening there.
We're really enjoying hearing how you are
processing the story and experiencing it.
It's a big part of our satisfaction,
like it feels like a completion
to hear from you guys,
in terms of having worked
so hard on this novel.
So, on Twitter, #BleakCreek,
at the Mythical Society,
and wherever you wanna discuss the novel.
We appreciate it.
And we're gonna enter that discussion,
so make sure you are
tagging all those things
so we can see 'em as we
begin to gather questions
and comments and insights and observations
that you have made about the book.
And then we're gonna do
a podcast sometime soon
where we enter into that conversation
and maybe offer some insights into that.
So what is this quiz?
There's a guy, let's see, where is he?
Where's he at?
He's in Lowell, Massachusetts.
His name is Mr. Callahan, he's a teacher.
There was an article,
at least in Buzzfeed,
I think it may have been
in other places as well,
earlier this year, where
he started to keep a list
of the words that he
heard his students using,
because he was like I'm lost,
I don't understand what this stuff means,
but every time I hear
them use a certain phrase
or a word that I don't understand,
that seems like there's a
generational divide here,
I'm going to write it down
and then get them to define it for me.
Okay, cool, and how old is he?
I don't know specifically.
I thought you told me
he was about our age.
Oh, yeah, 43, he's 43.
Yeah the article's like
43 year old teacher, yeah.
So he's our age, which makes
this even more relevant to us.
And he's--
Our irrelevance more relevant.
He's dealing regularly
with generation Z people,
which we do because we are parents to them
and also I know there's
a fair amount of people
born between '95 and 2015
who listen to this podcast
and enjoy the other things that we do.
So he started making this list,
and of course when word got out about
the fact that he had this list
he made it into a Google Doc that is now
publicly available to
anyone who wants to view it.
Yes, opensource it.
And I think the interesting
thing about this,
as opposed to simply
entering in these phrases
into the Urban Dictionary
and getting the definition,
which I could have done,
I wanted us to stick with Mr.
Callahan's list exclusively,
because I think that maybe
some of his definitions
are the definitions that he got
from his particular
students in Massachusetts.
Some people may, who know, you may have
a contention with one
of these definitions.
I don't know.
But this is the information
that he received.
You're gonna definitely know some of these
and you're definitely gonna not.
Hit me with one.
So, a force.
So starting with the first one.
Two words, a space force.
A force.
Yeah.
Like a force to be reckoned with.
It's a complimentary...
It's a way to describe
someone, like my neighbor,
who showers while staring
at me, is such a force.
Well that's your old
man's understanding of it.
Which is what I would agree with.
But it is unnecessarily excessive effort.
Okay, yeah, that man who
stares at me while showering
is a, okay, that's even
better, and more accurate.
Unnecessarily...
Don't read it 'cause you're
gonna read other things.
Unnecessarily excessive effort.
I don't even know how that
would be used in a sentence.
He's forcing it.
Oh that's a force.
Yeah.
Oh that was a force.
You're forcing it, you're trying to hard.
Now, we used to use
this, my dad would say,
like it's in sports language.
Like sometimes you'll
be shooting and you're
trying too hard, like
shooting the basketball,
he'd be like, "Don't
force it, don't force it."
Don't force it, let it come to you.
Just shoot it.
Just let it happen.
Just relax into it.
So is that the same thing?
I think so, yeah.
But it's a force.
They use it in a specific way.
They're not saying don't force
it, they're saying a force.
That's a force.
So there's no sentence.
No uses in a sentence.
Callahan needs a new
column in his Google Doc.
Yeah Mr. Callahan, we would invite you
to update your Google Doc.
But I mean he needs to
open it up for edits.
He needs to opensource it.
Bang 30s.
Never heard this.
I'm about to go bang 30s.
That means like I'm gonna,
I'm gonna take a power nap.
I'ma sleep for 30 minutes.
I'ma bang out 30.
Yeah.
Uh, that's not what it means.
Power naps taken for 30 minutes,
I think that's too long, isn't it?
Yeah, it should be 20, yeah.
Generation Z, they don't...
They're sleeping too much.
It means to fight someone,
as in a physical altercation.
So you've got my first plus my fist is 10.
Plus your fist and your fist is 20.
It's when three people fight.
No, I think it's my fist and my fist,
your fist and your fist, and
then either both of my feet,
both of your feet, or one of your foots,
and one of my feet.
But none of my feet.
Either both of your feet and none of mine
or one and one.
So it's a boxing match where
kicking with one leg is allowed.
But you don't know
where the 30 comes from.
I've no idea.
They're banging 30s in the common area,
we gotta call the po-po.
We gotta...
Bangin' 20s would have
made so much more sense.
Banging 20s.
Bangin' 30s.
Again, we have no...
Callahan's not giving us enough.
I mean do you wanna...
I just thought that we should just
let our ignorance be on display
and that might be more entertaining
than actually trying to
clarify some of this.
It doesn't seem like we're ignorant.
It also seems like we're crotchety old men
'cause we're complaining about
why it doesn't make sense
even though we've been told what it means.
Give me another one.
We can have opinions.
Beat your face.
Beat your face?
Yeah, beat your face.
Beat your face.
I'm getting frustrated
that there's no sentence.
'Cause I don't know,
is this an imperative?
Like hey man, beat your face.
How about this?
I thought my wife was ready,
but then I realized she
was still beating her face.
Putting on makeup?
Yeah.
Applying makeup.
Beat your face.
Also cake your face, but
cake your face is too easy.
Beat your face, I bet this came from the,
what are those people who make those
YouTube videos about makeup called?
Makeup people.
You don't know?
Makeup gurus?
Yeah.
Beauty gurus.
I bet it came from, I bet one of them.
Said beat your face?
'Cause here's the thing.
My kids have not said any of these.
My kids don't say lit,
they don't even say dope.
Like to me, the one that if I was going to
make a calculated effort
to try to speak gen-Z,
I'd say dope.
But I cannot bring myself to do it.
I've got too much pride and
I know that I don't mean it.
That's kinda old-school though,
but also, they also say it.
They all say it, right?
If something's good, if
something's cool or awesome,
they say, "That's dope, man."
Dope.
And dope's been around--
Hold on, does none of your kids say that?
My kids do not say that.
I think Locke says it sometimes, right?
Locke hasn't said any of these,
but Locke definitely,
because he's into hip-hop,
I've heard a number of these.
Maybe Lincoln has said it,
maybe Lincoln has said it,
'cause it's definitely that hip-hop,
pop culture influence there.
But I just...
Could you ever hear yourself saying--
That's dope?
Dope.
Actually, out of all
the things on this list,
dope feels like low hanging fruit.
I know, I know, that's why I'm asking.
That's dope, man.
Really, though?
Would you say it?
Could you say it?
I'm gonna say it today.
You're gonna try it out.
I'm gonna try it out.
I don't even think that's one though.
Is it?
I mean it's not on this list.
It just feels a little obvious.
But I do agree, they say it.
Now, here's the thing.
Let's go all the way.
We have to agree that we're cool with
each other saying dope,
'cause if we're not,
you know what's gonna happen.
Well you can't, if I say
it and you're around,
you can't look at me like
oh you just dropped it.
Can't do that.
And you can't do that to me,
because that's what we do.
We have this like...
We're very self aware, and,
I don't know, we have this,
and maybe it's a gift,
maybe it's a curse, but
we definitely have this
constant critic of ourselves that's like
how would other people be...
How would I be perceiving someone else
if they were doing or saying
what I'm doing right now?
That's self awareness, by my definition.
And then we have this second layer,
because we're together so much,
that we police each other,
so we're other aware.
So if either of us does anything that's
out of the ordinary, a little odd,
especially when it comes to like saying
something like dope,
it's a perfect example.
We'd be all over that for the other one
and be like, "Really?
"That aint you.
"You're frontin'."
I don't think I would say that
if you said something was dope,
I'd be like oh that's an...
Now if you said--
Sincerely though, if I said it sincerely,
I would know that something in your brain
had been triggered that was
like he's trying something.
It's like when I got those pants,
and I roll in with my
pants and you're like,
"Your pants are, what are
those, like hammer pants?"
I can't remember what you said,
they're like baggy pants, baggy jeans?
I don't know if I said anything about 'em.
You didn't have to say anything,
because I knew what you were thinking
because again, it's this
self policing thing.
You thought something.
You noticed the pants, you
decided not to say anything.
Well there was a big
difference from your pants
that you had been wearing.
And all of a sudden your pants
were very different, yeah.
Right.
So it's like, what I needed
from you man was permission.
I needed you to say--
You don't need permission from me.
I acknowledge your
pants, and you know what,
I don't know if I like 'em yet
but I applaud you expanding yourself.
Like literally, the pants are expanded.
You know, if you said something like that,
it's kinda like when we
devoted an entire hour
to talking about your hair growing out.
That's a little different.
That's not pants, I can't take it off.
But in the policing way,
I stepped out of the way.
Like you said your piece and
Like you knew that was not gonna be
any criticism from me
or constant judgment.
Like cutting my eyes, like
okay what is he doing?
I don't agree with this or
I think this is suspicious,
or this isn't really him.
You know?
Can we do that with the word dope?
I'm gonna say it today,
and we're going to two
different places today.
Together.
And I believe I will use
it in both circumstances.
I will say dope.
And maybe something else
that we learn about.
I have heard this one.
I think when I do it
I'ma, I'm gonna do it too.
Can we both do it?
No you need a different word.
You can't, it was my idea.
Okay, well then you can have dope,
I'm gonna do a different word.
We can't go into a place
where we're with somebody
and then both people are like,
"Rhett and Link both described
different things as dope."
See, you're so self aware, man.
Who cares what they think?
I don't really care, but if
we're doing an experiment
it needs to be...
We gotta set all the parameters.
It's like one person says
dope, see how it feels.
Two people say dope,
something's in the water.
Man, I'm nervous about...
I don't want people to be
like, "Rhett, you know--"
I'm getting flushed just thinking about
saying dope today, man.
You know what Rhett and Link
say when they like something,
they say it's dope.
I heard 'em both describe
this thing as dope,
within 30 minutes of each other.
'Cause awesome is tired.
Big tired.
And I just made that up, like I put big
in front of something,
and see that didn't work.
Okay, you gotta choose another word.
Well, let me get to some.
I've heard this one.
That's our dope experiment.
Bops.
Bops?
Now I know there's a
DaBaby song called Bop,
and he's talking about like
he's looking for a bop,
like he's looking for...
He wants his track to bop.
To him, it means, it means something
in terms of like the feel he gets,
it makes you kinda, it makes
you move in a certain way
that then you gotta do that certain
rhyme scheme that they
do now, the rappers.
I think you might be overthinking it.
I think it just means
like it's a good song,
like an enjoyable song.
He says a modern, enjoyable song.
Oh, okay.
I knew this one.
I think it can be used in
a couple of ways, because--
Shout out to DaBaby.
He's North Carolina.
I've heard Locke say that something bops.
That bops.
That's because, yeah, that's very hip-hop.
That bops, or I guess you
could say that's a bop.
I don't think you can say that's a bop.
Yeah I think you can.
That song...
That bops though I think is better.
It's more, like that's more refined.
It's like they wouldn't say
I'm looking for a banger.
You're looking for a bop now.
You don't want a banger anymore.
Bangers are over.
Bangers aren't dope.
We woulda just said a good hook.
Yeah, that's old school.
Well a hook applies to a
certain part of the song though.
That's a hit.
Ooh that's a hit.
That's what I would say.
I think you'd say, "Another one."
That's poppin'.
That's what you would say.
Poppin' might be on here.
A bop.
Is poppin' old?
I mean this is not a comprehensive list.
Now this one's...
He's got bouta in there.
Bouta.
Like bouta bouta.
No, B-O-U-T-A.
Like I'm about to, bouta.
That doesn't, I don't know if that should,
I think you should take that off the list,
Mr Calahan, because I think--
I'm bouta...
I'm bouta dance 30s, what was it, pop 30s?
Bang 30s.
I'm bouta bang 30s.
If you don't play my bop.
Now I've heard, there's two
different versions of this.
Catch a fade.
What's the other version?
Catch these hands.
Catch these hands?
Haven't heard that either.
Oh I've heard that.
My son has--
I think this is fighting too.
Like sometimes--
I'm bouta catch these hands.
Me and Locke will do
some like shadow boxing,
slap boxing type stuff and like you know,
I'll just see him in the kitchen,
I'll go up to him and hit him.
That's what we do in
the McLaughlin family,
just play fight.
And he's like, "You're gonna
catch these hands, dad."
I've never caught the hands.
But catch this fade.
Catch a fade is also.
I feel like a news anchor.
Catch a fade.
Is also acceptable.
I thought fade was a haircut.
That's what's--
I think it's if you like punch someone
on the side of the head
where they have a fade.
A glancing blow of the head.
Yeah.
If you give 'em a glancing
blow to the temple,
if you punch 'em in the temple,
that's where the fade is.
Technically, if you catch a fade
you would actually grab hold of the hair.
See now you're going too far.
Too literal.
You catch it with your face.
You beat your face.
But the idea of actually literally
catching someone's hands
who's trying to fight you,
that's awesome.
Like if I was like describing a fight,
a high school fight, and I was like,
"Dude, this dude totally
caught his hands."
Like he literally, he tried to punch him
and he caught his hands.
Yeah, yeah.
Punch me in the face right now.
Oh you see that.
That's like superhero stuff, man.
Yeah, man.
Punch me with the other hand.
Yeah see that, I caught your hands.
And now I'm gonna bang your hands together
and make a fire--
30 times?
Yeah.
Make a firework.
You only have to do it
three times to get to 30
'cause there's 10 fingers.
My dad would visit me in college,
and leading up to Christmas time,
or maybe it was my birthday.
I'm pretty sure it was Christmas time
'cause I remember buying winter clothes.
'Cause he would take me to the mall
and we'd go on like a shopping spree.
We did this for like two or
three years in a row in college.
And I remember what you said about how
you and Locke would like give
love licks to each other,
like punch each other.
I remember I was walking in
the Crabtree Mall with my dad
and we were shopping one Christmas,
and like I was buying stuff in the 90s.
And I was probably saying
stuff he didn't understand.
Yeah.
Awesome.
As a side note, I don't
remember that we were
like heavy into the like vernacular.
I do think a lot of it
comes from hip-hop culture,
like there's so many sayings.
And then there's the internet culture
and there's so many personalities.
Like not just beauty gurus,
but everybody on the internet
has a way of like coming
up with their phraseology
and then it kind of memeifying.
And I won't even get into memes yet.
But I don't recall, as a side note,
when I think back to walking
down the mall with my dad,
that we were saying those type of things.
I mean we listened to rap music,
but we also knew that it wasn't for us
to speak in the same way.
It wasn't popularized culture in the way
that hip-hop is now.
So I think...
We call things cool.
Something is cool, something is awesome.
We didn't use rad.
We actually never did rad.
Which, that's come back like a hip,
that's a hipster terminology now.
But when I was in California
like from ages three to five,
I specifically remember people saying rad.
'Cause that was like early 80s.
Well there was a surf
culture and skate culture,
also was a place that
had a lot of terminology.
They use the word tubular.
And gnarly.
And so a lot of those things...
So you have these subcultures.
Feldman remembers tubular.
Did you say tubular?
Did you ever use that, seriously?
Just the valley.
Totally dude.
But I was walking down there.
And I remember we were gonna buy some
big baggy jeans or something,
and I just reached over and I just,
I punched my dad in the shoulder,
just like a love lick, you know?
We didn't have that thing
that you and Locke have
where you're like shadow
boxing or whatever,
but like just as a show of affection,
we were in conversation,
I can't remember the specific context,
but I punched him in the shoulder.
And that was the end of it.
And then it was like a year later,
my dad is talking about his shoulder.
He's like, "Yeah I'm still having
"some trouble with my shoulder."
I'm like, "What do you mean?
"Because I actually have some
trouble with my shoulder,
"I think this might be a genetic thing,
"like my shoulder pops out of joint."
He's like, "Well, mine started when you
"punched me that day in the mall.
"I actually had to go to the doctor
"and he said that like a
ligament was separated."
I separated a ligament on my dad
trying to give him a love lick.
Listen, I've said this for years.
This is why I don't, any
time we have to do something
where it requires you hitting
me or you doing something,
you don't know your own
strength or you don't,
or you try to do it a little bit harder.
You hit him too hard, man.
Well obviously, and I
felt horrible about it.
I mean...
You've never permanently injured me.
I wasn't trying to prove anything.
It was obviously--
No I'm just saying it's like, you did it,
it was excessive.
So I tell Lincoln, like Lincoln will start
to roughhouse me and I'm like very,
especially 'cause I actually
do have shoulder issues,
and I'm doing like physical
therapy for my shoulder,
because I have hyper mobility.
That's what I'm diagnosed
with, like all my joints,
my shoulder joints and
elbow joints are like,
they're a little too mobile
and they're not supported enough.
So we'll start roughhousing,
'cause I'll grab him
and put him in a bear hug or something.
And I'm very aware, the
combination of what I did
to my dad and then how my shoulder feels.
Like he's gonna do the same thing to me
and it's gonna be a legacy.
That would not be lit or dope.
I will never say lit.
Like dope I think I can do.
Something about the way
your mouth is shaped.
And you can say it kinda
under your breath, like dope.
But like lit, it's like it's lit.
You gotta say it like
Travis Scott or something.
Sometimes they say litty.
I've heard Locke say litty,
which is an alteration of lit.
You know this one, clap back, that's easy.
That's when you retort.
You give back what they gave to you.
Yeah, you get an insult,
you respond with it,
you call a greater insult.
But clapped.
Clapped.
Now, I mean back in 90s hip-hop culture--
The clap.
The clap was...
Was an STD.
STI, we'll call it.
Don't call 'em a disease anymore,
you call it an infection.
Infection, okay.
Yeah, an STI.
All right.
Formerly known as an STD.
Why did they have to change that?
I dunno, just so it's more approachable.
I don't know.
Is it always an infection?
I think so, yeah.
What if it's just
sometimes it's a disease?
Uh,
because disease--
Because a disease is not
something that can be,
is necessarily transmitted.
That can be something that is just a--
I don't think that's the reason.
I think it might be because--
'Cause it could be a genetic disease.
An infection implies like I guess
you can take penicillin and cure it.
You can get rid of it.
But also an infection can be passed,
and a disease doesn't
necessarily have to be
a communicable disease, it can
be an incommunicable disease,
or it can be a genetic disease.
And so you can't give somebody
a sexually transmitted genetic disease,
unless they're you're offspring.
And at that point it all breaks down.
Like if you have a weird penis.
What?
Like if you have like a--
That's not, what?
I've got an STD, it's called weird penis.
You got a weird penis.
I'm saying like if you got something
genetically wrong with your penis,
that would be considered a disease
and you pass the weird penis
syndrome onto your child.
That could be, that's
technically a sexually
transmitted disease
because it was genetic.
No it's not.
And you had to have sex to have a kid.
You're wrong!
You're wrong in so many places.
I'm demonstrating why they
don't use STD anymore,
'cause it's STI.
I'm sorry I brought it up
'cause neither one of us know.
I have herpes on my mouth.
Do you have the clap?
I don't have the clap, and
I don't know what the clap--
What is the clap, is that syphilis?
I don't know.
What is the clap?
Can somebody look that up?
Somebody clap back on the clap.
Everyone is afraid to Google
the clap on the work wifi.
Gonorrhea.
And now they've got super gonorrhea.
You heard about this?
Well this is, okay.
We don't know how to speak to the children
but we have so much
information that they need.
My new favorite superhero,
super gonorrhea.
Super gonorrhea is basically
a lot of infections,
a lot of viral infections, are
becoming impossible to treat.
Or bacterial, both.
Basically completely immune to treatment.
And so if you get the strain of gonorrhea
that they can't treat anymore,
you got super gonorrhea and I
just think it never goes away.
Unless you've got weird penis syndrome,
which at that point it counteracts it.
Yeah, so you don't want gonorrhea
and you definitely don't
want super gonorrhea.
And ironically the people
who need to communicate
these things the most, need to be able to
speak the language of gen-Z.
So you're saying that like
if we make a brochure,
like what your mother would have had
at the health department,
it's all about STIs,
it needs to say things
like, "Got the clap?
"Well clap back."
Clap back on the clap.
Clap back on the clap with a condom.
That's a little too late.
Clap back on the clap with--
Get ahead of the clap.
Penicillin.
Okay, yeah.
I don't know if penicillin works anymore.
Clapped means a crazy
person, which even that,
I don't think gen-Z even
uses the term crazy anymore.
That's not PC, you can't
call somebody crazy.
Or someone who was punched.
I don't know, these people
up in Massachusetts,
I don't know if this is
representative of all of gen-Z,
Mr Callahan.
There's a lot of reference to fighting.
Man, he got clapped 'cause
he caught them hands.
Cracky.
Crikey?
Crikey.
No not crikey.
Crikey
That should be on the list.
Cracky.
That's when you're like,
when you laugh a lot.
If only it were that simple.
Man, Don is so cracky, he
can't hold it together.
It's someone who joules, vapes.
Vapes, it's a vaper.
It's like you have an addictive habit.
Man, these kids, man.
They're vaping like crazy, man.
Like Locke said that basically any time
you go in the bathroom at their school,
where all our kids go now.
Yeah I encourage my kids to
use the restroom frequently.
Because like I encourage
them to be hydrated.
Now that might be working against me,
'cause now there's a
lot of vaping happening.
Well they're getting
second hand vapes, man.
'Cause the kids are vaping in there,
and I don't understand why they can't...
Kids are vaping like in class.
I think they have cracked down on it.
Cracky, speaking of cracky.
I think they've cracked
down on it a little bit.
But there's stories of people--
There's people dying!
I mean with the people dying
and they were trying to
get to the bottom, as of this recording,
they're still trying to get to the bottom
of what's killing these--
Oh you think some time
between the recording of this
and the publishing they're gonna solve it.
You're very hopeful.
Breaking news every day.
I mean there's like black
market vapes being created,
but they haven't definitely said
that that's what it's associated with.
But all vaping is most likely bad for you.
And not just the nicotine,
which kids shouldn't have,
which we talked about when we
had the surgeon general on.
We had the surgeon
general on, remember that?
On Good Mythical Morn.
Anti vaping thing.
Lot of good that did.
It was funny because
there's a couple of like,
there's these vaping YouTube channels,
there was a couple who like came after us
and they were like,
"Rhett and Link don't know
what they're talking about.
"Vaping is completely safe.
"They're speaking out of ignorance."
Listen, whatever they find, right,
whatever they find and
I know that some people
who are dying are probably
getting like black market stuff
that's got other chemicals
in it or whatever,
but the bottom line is your
lungs were made to breathe air.
Right?
So changing the concentration
that drastically
of whatever it is you're
putting into your body,
even if it isn't combusting
at the same temperature
that tobacco would be combusting at,
it can't be good.
This is not a good thing.
And if you're cracky,
meaning you're on that thing
all the time, nicotine
is highly addictive.
Well and the reason--
And then you're ingesting
this vapor all the time.
It is so much more...
You're doing so much more than you
typically would with
smoking because at least,
when we were coming up,
if you wanted to smoke
you had to go to the, we had a smoking pit
at Harnett Central High School.
There was a smoking pit.
I'm sure they don't have this anymore.
But basically there was that depressed,
literally depressed and also
physically depressed area,
that people stood out there and smoked.
But you had to go out there to do it,
so how many cigarettes are you gonna
get to smoke in a day, right?
Yeah.
But with this vape you can just,
they're doing it in class.
Crackies everywhere, man.
Don't be a cracky.
Find a new hobbie.
We're not even out of the Cs.
Cherry pick a little bit, 'cause,
I also wanna talk about the dynamic of...
I think our, like us having
children at the age they are now
is a dynamic that I'd like to explore.
Finesse.
I've heard this one.
Is this a noun or a verb?
This is a verb.
Well if you finesse something or someone
you like, you take a light
touch to get what you want.
I can't think that it
means exactly that there.
It means to steal.
Oh, to steal?
I'm gonna finesse your mug.
It's kinda like you got sticky fingers,
but a light,
you can stick your hand
on somebody's pocket
and pull out a wallet
and they won't know it
'cause you're very finesse.
Finesse is also a hairspray.
It is.
Now, okay, of course
everyone knows low key,
and their is a high key.
Thor and Loki.
My kids use low key.
And high key.
I low key am into this, I
high key want to have that.
It's a qualifier.
Low key, it's like it
could be on the down low.
You haven't heard this from your children?
They don't say it.
Don't say low key?
Mm-mm.
Like low key is probably
the most common one
that I've heard amongst, on this list.
I've also heard this one.
Locke says this all the time.
Facts.
Now to me that's meme
speak, and I think that...
I don't know how I know
but I can just tell
when my kids go into meme speak.
Lily does this a lot.
I mean she created a Pinterest account
just to save memes that she can go back to
and laugh at and like snicker
to herself on her phone--
Snicker, you need a better word than that.
She can cracky up with herself.
No, she's not...
Look for one that is what
you do with memes, but...
And then she'll say it and
it won't be just like yeet,
but I can just tell, she
goes into this speak that
oh, you just quoted a meme, did you not?
And she's like, "Yeah."
I used to be like, "Well show it to me."
You know, 'cause it conjures
up this visual that's been--
Why are you saying that
about facts though?
Because I think that facts is meme speak,
like people will write some,
there'll be a statement,
and then it'll just say facts.
And you say facts when
it's like somebody says
something that you strongly agree with.
I think that's what it means.
Yeah that's definitely what it means,
and I'm sure it could be in a meme,
but like it's also just, it just is slang.
If somebody says something like facts.
But you see it in meme form a lot,
and I don't know which came first,
but I know there's lots
of things that my kids say
that they're just quoting
memes to each other,
conjuring a visual image
that's a shared experience
and it makes the other person laugh.
It's like an inside joke.
I mean my opinion, I'm just like yeet it.
Yeet it.
Do you know where yeet came from?
Some kid who threw something,
and when he threw it he said, "Yeet!"
And then that's where it came from.
So it was just a little video that
people passed around with
this kid saying yeet,
and then yeet started to
mean throwing something.
Yeah that's special.
That's special, man.
I like that.
That's the internet.
Oh, okay.
There's a few here that
are very old school
and I guess they're coming back,
at least they're coming
back in Massachusetts,
in Mr. Calahan's class.
Get hip, means to adopt a new trend,
which is what it meant for us.
Jams, an old enjoyable song.
Like that's my jam.
Okay, yeah.
I'm dead.
It's like...
I think we elicit that response a lot.
I see that in response to things
that we've done on our show.
It's like it shook you in a positive way.
It was amusing.
Yeah.
I'm dead.
Shook you in a positive way.
I'm shook.
Shook could be like
moved in a negative way.
Yeah.
I'm shook.
I don't know what to say man.
Real one.
Real one?
Yeah.
That's referring to a
person who's authentic,
and you like 'em.
A valid person, somebody you trust.
He's a real one.
Um.
No cap.
No cap, man.
Are you using an accent?
Why are you using an accent?
I'm using a generation Z.
Like slightly informed by hip-hop.
Like I listen to hip-hop sometimes.
Like your eyebrows have
to kinda like go up--
No cap, man.
Your eyebrows kinda have to
go together a little bit.
No cap.
That's, I mean, it's really,
when you do your eyebrows
like that you start to
seem like you're saying
something that's a little more cool.
No cap means no limit.
I can't be contained.
No, too literal.
It means I'm serious, no lie, for real.
This one's interesting.
Period T.
It's period with a t on
the end and I don't know
if that is a typo by Mr. Callahan--
Like a dot and a t?
It's just period and then--
The word period?
And then T on the end of
it, as if it's periodt.
Periodt.
I'm sure that's how they say it.
It says see facts.
Now it does remind me of tsk tsk tsk,
which is that, do you know
about these VSCO girls?
Oh.
I know, we sound so old.
You mean the ones with the cameras.
No.
It's girls, again I think, Lincoln knows,
Lincoln, he said he
wanted to be this for hal,
he said, "I wanna be a
VSCO girl for Halloween."
I'm like, "I've heard a little
bit but tell me about that."
And he was like, "You have a hydro flask,
"you have a lot of
scrunchies in your hair,
"and maybe on your arms.
"You like have a hat or a shirt that says
"like save the turtles and
you're wearing yoga pants.
"You're wearing Lululemon."
Right but where does the VSCO come from?
I don't know.
V-S-C-O.
I thought that, I think, well...
I thought it had something
to do with a camera.
And I'm like so are you kinda talking like
a girl who seems like
she's coming from the gym
but she never went to
the gym but she likes
environmental causes and
she has like a high ponytail
like Ariana Grande?
And he's like, "Yeah."
What is it?
Generally used as an insult
for a young woman who
posts trendy pictures
of herself edited on the app VSCO.
Yeah yeah, see I told you.
There's an app called VSCO.
But that's what they look like.
Right, it's a type of
person who uses that app.
I can imagine that.
He decided to be an e-boy.
Which I was like, what is that, emo?
And he was like...
What is an e-boy?
Yeah.
He's like, "You know,
you wear like a chain."
Halloween, okay.
Yeah for Halloween.
And you wear like black and white clothes
and you part your hair down the middle.
'Cause I was like, "I got a
pizza costume you could wear."
And he's like, "Dad I wanna
look cool for Halloween."
Well be an e-boy then.
You'll slay.
Oh slay is one?
What do you think...
I mean we're obviously
really showing our dad.
I don't think this...
Are we actually more in touch
with the fact that we're,
or are we more...
Let me ask that again.
Are we more in touch than we think,
or are we more in touch
that we're out of touch
because of the age of our kids?
What's the dynamic there?
Well, I feel like...
I think what you talked about earlier
in this sort of self regulating
tendency that we have.
Both to regulate ourselves
and regulate one another.
It makes adopting like a new
word into your terminology,
it makes it,
it makes us really
hesitant to do that, right?
And so, 'cause it's like
what does that say about me
if I'm suddenly using this new word?
And so we haven't picked
up on a lot of new...
We haven't changed the
way that we've talked,
in terms of the terminology,
a lot over time.
But what we have done, as
illustrated by your big pants,
is we've kinda, in ways that maybe people
that we went to high school with,
that didn't choose to be
YouTubers for a living,
don't necessarily follow the trends.
Now one of the things...
We've talked about fashion before,
so we were gonna do a podcast about that,
but we're not.
But one of the things I was
talking about with Jessie,
I was like something about
now that I've got kids who...
Like I've got a teenager in my house,
and if I were to just say I'm gonna go to
Urban Outfitters and I'm
just gonna buy everything
on the rack at Urban
Outfitters and dress that way,
now I'm dressing the same
way as my 15 year old kid.
And at some point it kinda feels like
I don't wanna do that anymore.
And I told Jessie, I was like,
"Is it because Locke is now a teenager
"and then we're going into the same store
"and we're looking at the same clothes,
"and for the first time ever I'm just
"going into a place like Urban Outfitters
"and just thinking I don't know if there's
"anything in here for me."
And she said, "Well, it
could be a part of it,
"but I also think that
you've gotten to an age
"where you kinda know
what looks good on you.
"You kinda know what
shapes look good on you,
"and you may not like the shapes."
Like Shia LaBeouf said on Hot Ones.
And that brought us back to our favorite
Hot Ones episode ever of Shia LaBeouf
talking about how the way he sees clothes
is he just thinks about shapes,
he doesn't think about colors or patterns.
He thinks about shapes.
And I was like I've never
connected more with something.
I think about shapes, and it probably has
something to do with just being a big man.
But anyway, I found myself
resistant, like you know,
and you've always been a little bit more,
like if there's a fashion
trend that's gonna happen,
you're gonna open that
door earlier than I am.
And I've got reasons I won't go into
that are boring about
why I think I delay that.
But, this latest trend with the 90s
and all the athletic
clothes and the boxy things
and the block colors and
horizontal stripes and all this.
I'm not on board for this one.
And I feel like I'm kind of
taking an exit a little bit.
Like I've been on this
interstate for a while
that's sorta like okay I'm kinda
conscious of fashion trends
and I try to do something
that seems fashionable
and I kinda dress like a young person,
but I've gotta feel like I'm on the exit.
And I'm like I'm 42, I think
I'm gonna have my own style
and I'm not gonna be too worried about
what the general style is anymore.
And I'm just gonna wear
what I feel good in.
You know what I'm saying?
The decision I've made is more about
I'm gonna get on a parallel highway
that still is moving.
I like trying new things,
but I don't wanna emulate,
I don't wanna start looking like my son.
I mean a lot of shirts
are getting a little
too small for me, I end
up giving 'em to Lincoln.
He likes maybe a third of 'em.
He'll wear some of 'em.
But yeah, that's waning.
It's just a different aesthetic.
But I like to have fun with an aesthetic.
But I just want it to be my own thing.
It's not just exiting and like parking.
It's like well I'm just gonna,
I'm gonna go full dad.
I agree with that.
Pop out to Gap.
Well that's what I don't wanna do because,
you got somebody like...
I don't go on Facebook anymore,
but in the same way
like personally going on
and looking at old friends
photos and stuff like that.
But I remember a decade ago
when I did such a thing,
you'd go on there and so a decade ago
I'm just over 30 years
old, and you go on there
and you see somebody you
went to high school with
and you're like man, that
dude has just, he's old.
It isn't oh he aged.
It might be that with
somebody who's like lost hair
or their hair turned gray
or something like that.
A lot of it is conformity.
They made an aesthetic
decision to be like...
This is my job, I'm a professional,
and so I'm going to dress
and behave the same way
that everyone else at
this place of work does.
Up to age 65/70 years old, right?
And so it's just like you
see this 30 year old person
and you're like man, you
don't seem youthful anymore,
you seem old, because you've conformed.
Instead of there being a slow progression
you just said I gotta get under this lane,
I gotta get into professional lane,
so now I got my polo
tucked into my khakis.
Right.
But we are in the art lane.
If you wanna go, and so
that's one of the things
I love about, you know,
where I'm at in my life,
is that especially in
this town where there's
no judgment for anybody being anything
they wanna be and expressing themselves
because there's so much
of an art centered town.
Nobody looks at you
funny if you dress weird.
So it's not that I wanna
stay relevant to the kids,
it's that I wanna be
able to express myself
and say, you know, I don't wanna conform,
I don't wanna conform to
them, 'cause that's kinda sad.
It's like okay, you're in
your 40s, you're trying to...
If this is how you're trying to connect
with your 16 and 14 year
old, by dressing like them?
At any moment you could--
Crash their party?
Well, get into some sort of--
Like a narc.
Ambiguous athletic event.
Like maybe there's a uniform
under that tracksuit.
Right.
Yeah it aint gonna work for us.
But tracksuits are classic
though, I will say that.
Still think we can do tracksuits.
Find something.
Yeah you could do that.
I gave up on that.
Well you took that, you
wore that tracksuit on GMM.
It really caused a ruckus.
I couldn't even wear it the whole episode.
Couldn't even.
Well, um--
But hold on, but I didn't relate it back
to what we're talking about.
Relate it and let's shut this down,
'cause that'd be a dope way to end it.
Oh there you go, okay.
I think you've gotta
use it in mixed company
before it really counts,
so that was a nice try.
To relate it back to this, and
the question that you asked,
which is like are we out of touch?
You haven't picked your word, by the way.
What's your word?
What word do you actually
think you can use?
Facts.
That could be tough to come with.
That's a tough one because
it's so definitive.
It's a closing statement.
Like when you say facts,
whoever you're talking to
has nothing to say.
It's just like oh he just said facts.
Facts.
Facts is the end of a thought,
but dope can just, you
can nestle it in there.
It's a response though, if
somebody says something facts.
You know what, I could
do low key or high key.
Would that be weird?
Yes but I think that's a good idea.
Are we back tracking on what we just said?
Are we...
That's low key.
We gotta try it, okay.
I know that this is inconsistent with what
I just said about getting on my own lane
and being an artist and expressing myself.
I feel like dope is really
easy, it's almost too easy.
I legitimately like hip-hop, okay?
I don't like it so that
my son will like me.
So don't judge me.
Shlitty's a good time.
I love the rhythms.
I'm gonna do facts.
Facts, man.
All right.
I'ma be waiting with
baited breath for that one.
But to relate what I was just
saying about the fashion,
back to this, is I do think that I am...
With the fashion thing there's been
a little bit more effort, right?
And I do think that some
of it is the fact that
we're free to dress how we want to,
no one's gonna fire us
for dressing a certain way
and there's no dress code.
Is there a dress code?
I mean there probably
is a dress code here,
like you can't wear a
thong and nothing else
at Mythical Entertainment.
And if we haven't specified that yet
we should probably put that
in the employee handbook.
Wow.
But you can dress how you want.
And we've taken full
advantage of that, right?
Well, we haven't worn a thong.
Not yet.
Facts.
Okay that didn't work.
But with terminology, lingo,
we've pretty much continued
to talk the same way.
Now we've lost our accent
that we had in North Carolina,
for the most part, it comes
back at certain times.
But that's really a function
of hearing yourself,
hours and hours of your
own voice heard back,
you end up, it happens
with a lot of people,
your voice, you end up kinda changing--
What are you getting at?
I'm just saying that I feel absolutely
no compulsion to try to use any of this.
But we just came up with a compulsion,
that you were gonna do it.
Yeah we're gonna do it because it's fun.
We're gonna do it because it's fun,
and hey, maybe we'll learn something.
We'll let you know.
But you let us know,
#EarBiscuits, if you disagree.
Just feel free to put us
on blast, as they say.
That's good.
Rec baby, rec baby, one two three four.
Rec baby, rec baby, one two.
You know what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna make a recommendation for y'all.
I'm actually recommending this to you
'cause I think you'll like it.
I went into a bookstore because I was told
that Lost Causes of
Bleak Creek had a placard
at Vroman's Bookstore in Pasadena
so I went over there
and they didn't have it.
This was over a month ago now.
And I was in there, I
was like you know what,
I'm in a freaking bookstore,
it's so sad, but I was like--
Maybe you should buy a book.
Maybe I should buy a book.
'Cause I was just thinking I'm just gonna
look around at all these books,
but I never thought I'd actually buy one
'cause I didn't think
I'd actually read one.
'Cause I'd gotten outta the habit.
But I picked up a book,
and I will recommend it,
because I'm really enjoying it.
The reason why...
For some reason I went
to the sci-fi section.
I was like I want a good sci-fi book.
Got a book called The Three-Body Problem.
And honestly, one of the
reasons that I got it
was because it won an
award, it won the Hugo Award
for best novel in 2015.
It's part of a trilogy of novels,
so if I really like it
then I can kinda dig in,
'cause I really like to dig
into a world if I like it.
That's why once I started
reading Game of Thrones
I read all of 'em.
It's originally written in Chinese
and translated into
English, which concerned me,
but it has no impact.
And then what sealed the
deal and counteracted that
and made me buy it, not only
did it have a cool cover,
but Barack Obama endorsed it.
Wildly imaginative.
Endorsement's really move you.
How do you get Barack Obama
to endorse your sci-fi novel?
He's a sci-fi fan.
Wildly imaginative.
That's what he said.
I was like man, I gotta get this.
The Three-Body Problem is a
hard science fiction novel.
Hard science fiction.
I'm going hard.
It is the first novel of the
Remembrance of Earths Passed trilogy
by writer Liu Cixin.
That's all I'm gonna say.
If you're into...
Oh man this thing's...
It's not very long either, right?
It's 320 something pages,
is that what it said?
A lot of times sci-fi is so long that,
my attention span is like not great.
I'm halfway through like
so many books right now.
302 pages.
Oh yeah, that's great.
So I'm halfway through.
It's a fun, wildly imaginative book.
Yeah it's got VR.
The Three-Body Problem.
You'll like it because there's a whole--
That probably was a
catchier title in Chinese.
The Three-Body Problem actually references
a problem in physics,
in orbital mechanics,
according to the Wikipedia.
So there's a lot of physics involved,
lot of smart scientists are like
the key people in this thing.
But it's also like inter,
like being ready for
inter-dimensional battle.
And I'm only halfway through the book, so,
I could spoil some things
but there's some things
I'm still like is there
something alien going on here?
I actually, I don't fully know yet.
But there's a lot of VR.
There's an amazing VR
game within the book.
The way that that world works--
Sounds like it slaps.
It slaps.
It's dope.
That's my rec.
I'll check it out.
Yeah check it out.
#EarBiscuits.
We'll speak at you next week.
Speak at us that way.
To watch more Ear Biscuits click on
the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.